let's get more now on brexit life to
Hull in the north of England an area
that voted overwhelmingly for brexit
Emma Heywood brings us reaction from
there so Emma where you are is there a
sense of yes just do it because it's
been going on for so long very much a
sense of just get on with it get brexit
over the line most of the people we have
spoken to still say that when they put
the cross in the box
saying they wanted to leave the European
Union they were doing the right thing
and frustration I think that there's any
kind of delay to the process I think
many people here believe that it should
have been sorted out a long time ago
well let speak to Dave Harding he's a
trade unionist here in the city Dave do
you think this delay is important at all
it is important but getting out of
Europe is very very important however
it's it's right it's important that we
do it right but if we're going to have a
deal but the deal is rights because any
mistake that's made now well it will
affect us and affect us for generations
to come so yes it is important that we
though do get it right and if let's say
we do do delay an expectation here that
brexit will happen and should happen and
why do you think people still feel so
strongly about it more than three years
on after the referendum absolutely
pierre people feel it's right so that we
leave the EU people voted for it three
years ago because they thought it was
right then and they feel it's right now
and there's going to continue to feel
that way because it is the right thing
to do there was a sense of sense
overwhelming majority to actually leave
the EU in this city and it's important
that that is done but as I said before
it's important it's done correctly
because any mistake will have a massive
massive negative effects are not just
our region but other regions across the
country why do you think people voted
that way and still feel that way why
what was the root cause of that was it a
protest vote you think obviously there's
going to be part of that but people are
just fed up of Europe of the unelected
bureaucrats if you like of not having a
voice within within that within that
Parliament because they want to be
governed by a parliament that's in this
country by people that they trust Europe
the European Union has invested millions
of dollars in the city have made so
I think I've done a bad job marketing
themselves and people just aren't aware
of what they've done for this city
government shouldn't be about marketing
yes they had an obligation to to invest
where necessary in the same way that the
UK government also has an obligation to
to invest in poor poorer communities and
it's something which the UK government
hasn't done for over 50 years and they
need to start doing that right now and
and to do it and do it properly so
that's whole and other cities but like
coal can throw and can thrive in a
economy which is outside Europe clearly
there needs to be some kind of clarity
does that for business a lot of
businesses here manufacturing the supply
chain always rely on close connections
with Europe though don't they
I've got well we report here in hope and
of course we do but that doesn't mean
that we can't get goods and services
from Europe it just changes the way that
we actually actually deal with them but
no no one's saying we're going to cast
Europe aside or we're going to be
completely independent of course we've
got to have some sort of relation which
is why any deal that we do is done
correctly Dave Harding thank you very
much for joining us on al-jazeera well
we've spent the last couple of days here
in Hull and most people we have spoken
to still believe that Britain should
leave the EU but it's interesting you
know you go not that far away to your
core a bit further down south to the
east of England to Cambridge and you
would hear probably a very different
viewpoint altogether bricks it is so
divisive in this country
Emma thanks very much